un momento de respiro después de años de
sufrimiento así reaccionaron los
familiares de la matanza de Sandy Hook
tras la sentencia contra el
ultraderechista Alex Jones quien por
años sostuvo que el tiroteo fue una
mentira después en las afueras de un
juzgado de Connecticut celebraron
no podría estar más orgulloso de estar
aquí con todas estas personas a pesar de
extrañar a mi esposa e hija en este
momento
Habrá más Alex Jones en este mundo pero
lo que se aprendió hoy aquí es que serán
absolutamente responsables
Alex Jones líder del portal infowards
fue condenado a pagar cerca de mil
millones de dólares a una docena de
familiares de víctimas de la matanza de
Sandy Hook lo denunciaron por daños y
amenazas que sufrieron como consecuencia
de sus afirmaciones conspiranoicas de
que los muertos eran en realidad actores
que falsificaron la tragedia esto en un
complot del gobierno para llevarse las
armas de los estadounidenses El
condenado considera exagerada la
sentencia
su reacción fue que ya lo habían
declarado culpable antes de que tuviera
la oportunidad de defender este caso y
que la primera enmienda está bajo asedio
y entonces espera continuar luchando por
la libertad de expresión
el 14 de diciembre de 2012 en la escuela
primaria de Sandy Hook en Newton 20
niños y seis trabajadores fueron
asesinados a tiros fue en ese entonces
la peor masacre en un centro de
Educación primario secundaria de la
historia de Estados Unidos 10 años
después el no ha terminado sumándose a
una larga lista de tiroteos el pasado 24
de mayo 21 personas fueron asesinadas en
una escuela de uval de Texas por lo que
el debate sobre el control de armas
sigue sobre la mesa con un dato en 2020
se vendieron más de 23 millones
récord histórico